how to report the results of the man
Whitney you test we adhere to the APA
style guidelines first of all what is a
man with new test a man Whitney Utes
tests whether there is a difference
between two independent samples and the
man with new test is the non-parametric
counterpart to the t-test for
independent samples but how to report
the man with new test reporting the
results of the man with new test
according to APA style requires
presenting key statistics and findings
in a clear concise manner here's a
general guideline on how to report the
results in six steps number one specify
the test and purpose start by specifying
that you performed a man with new test
and briefly explain the purpose of the
test eg a man with new test was
conducted to compare scores between
group a and Group B number two report
the use statistic clearly report the use
statistic value EG U is equal to
105. number three report the
significance level indicate the exact
p-value obtained if the p-value is less
than
0.001 you can report it as P smaller
0.001 if the p-value is for example
0.045 you would report it as P equal to
0.045 number four sample size mention
the sample size of each group EG and 1
is equal to 30 and 2 is equal to 25.
number five effect size report the
effect size like R and describe its
magnitude R is equal to 0.34 indicating
a medium effect size number six
summarize the results after presenting
the statistics provide a summary
sentence to explain the meaning of the
results in the context of your study the
results suggest that group a has
significantly higher scores than Group B
and here is a complete example a man
with new test was conducted to compare
scores between group a and Group B the
test revealed a significant difference
between the two groups U is equal to 105
and 1 is equal to 30 and 2 is 25 p is
equal to
0.045 with a medium effect size R is
equal to 0.34 the result suggest that
group a has significantly higher scores
than Group B of course when you
calculate a man with new test online
with data tab the summary in words is
autumn medically generated for you just
select your variables and click on
non-parametric and then on summary in
words
remember the key to reporting in APA
style is Clarity and conciseness make
sure that your audience can easily
understand the statistical test you used
the key results and the implications of
these results thanks for watching and I
hope you enjoyed the video